okay so a little update and before i get
in to the update i want to be really
clear um
i don't think i've ever experienced
better care than at the mayo clinic
there are levels to this thing and i
cannot recommend them enough they're not
a sponsor obviously i have no vested
interest in it but uh my near-death
experience is entirely
the result of my stupidity and has
nothing to do
with anything uh the doctors had done as
a matter of fact i did the opposite so
um
i i guess yeah last we left you know i
uh
a bit of a cliffhanger uh
i i almost almost died came pretty
pretty close to it
um
i uh
woke up in the middle of night having
trouble breathing
and it got to the point where
i felt like i just could not get oxygen
and uh
it really felt like if it got one
percent worse than
i was gonna die
let me explain to you exactly what
happened so basically if you go on the
the mayo clinic website
and and read about the recovery for a
procedure like this uh it's 12 weeks
before you're back to work
you know minimum
but i did have a lot of external
pressures
to
try and come back sooner so i thought i
could do it in four
i pushed too hard um
i was doing too much
and
you know but my body told me
who told you you could do that and i
paid for it after the procedure after
the surgery i
was doing a lot of walking and moving
around and stares and stuff which was
ill-advised but i kept getting winded
just going up the stairs doing basic
things and
uh my breath registering on the
spirometer kept getting worse
that's not so bad it's better than
before
but when it was really bad it was a
little between a thousand and
twelve fifty
now it's at
3 500. it feels like a toy so i went in
to a local hospital got an x-ray and
they said
well one of the lungs has collapsed so
it's really because you're not breathing
enough you're not expanding that lung
um so they gave me some breathing
exercises probably about four days after
that
it was
night time
i had to walk up the stairs to go to bed
and i remember getting really dizzy
kind of you know
seeing stars
and short of breath once i i laid down
on my back with my
glorified sex pillow that i have to
have to it's like it's my mom bought it
for me so this is how this will support
your thoracic spine it's a it it's a sex
pillow i saw in the back of hamach or
schlemmer but it helps the breathing
became so labored that i i couldn't uh
i could not only get a full breath
um
it was
everything i had everything my diaphragm
my muscles
that that was about it
i just kept thinking okay this
how much worse is this going to get
don't stop breathing don't stop
breathing and i would fade out and come
back to but right away the first thing
was if i woke up it was don't stop
breathing don't stop breathing
and it just it just got so much worse
throughout the night and i remember
uh i really do i remember prying saying
hey just
either let this be something that just
is nothing and break through and it's
fine or
you know or take take me now just don't
let me don't let me feel like i'm
drowning to death
all night
um so finally it got to be about i don't
know maybe four in the morning and i can
feel myself going out at this point and
not only can i feel myself going out but
i i can feel the exhaustion of my
muscles from breathing that's when i
remember getting really scared you know
how sometimes i always wonder this you
would watch in the films and you see
people just sort of stop breathing and
you wonder well just keep keep breathing
it's almost like drowning right your
muscles are too tired and you can't swim
and you sink even though you think well
do whatever it takes to swim it doesn't
matter what your fight or flight
instinct is
at a certain point
the muscles
and the mechanics required to keep
breathing
they're just they're just not there you
don't have never-ending supply of energy
and so it's four in the morning and i
remember thinking okay
getting light-headed i might go out
and
was really scared that i wouldn't have
the energy to to breathe
while i was out so i
called
uh my best friend who's downstairs
didn't answer texted him texted my dad
and then called through to my dad about
three or four times to get through you
know the emergency call whenever it's in
do not disturb or something
and um
the answer to what was going on and i
could only get one word out
with every breath
okay
dad
and so i won't put you back it won't put
you through that like the black in the
wheelchair and malcolm in the middle but
that's what it actually was like and i i
told my dad that i thought that this
could be the last time that i ever spoke
with him
so something woke my friend up from the
basement i just got a call from stephen
he says he's he can't breathe he feels
like he's drowning so get him up get him
in the car and get him out to the
hospital get him to the yard came up
hightailed it to the emergency room
uh
long story short
what had happened was because i had
pushed things too far
uh i tried to do too much and this is a
lesson to everyone out there and this is
why the delays happened and coming back
in september i just i i can't tell you
how much i'm
looking forward to being well enough to
do the show again with the guys i think
september 7th the first day after labor
day
um
i think there was some soft tissue
damage i don't know they removed five to
six liters
of fluid and you can see
uh probably i've showed you
largely bloody
from my lung cavity to the point where
my left lung think of water pressure was
completely closed and my right was
mostly closed and once they finally
drained it i i felt so much better
there's still a lot of pain to deal with
a lot of you know recovery and tissue
stuff but uh
that was scary it was scary and i don't
know how many of you out there you know
you can look you can comment below
if you've ever been in those i've had
one other situation i think i've talked
about on air where i thought okay this
is it this is curtains
but this was different
uh
and then i had time to think about it
and it wasn't panic
it was very rational i had a whole night
to think about it and i remember that
moment when i started seeing the stars
and the air is being pushed out and i'm
not able to get air in and i can sense
that i am going to go out and faint
thinking what do you have to get done
and i think that's kind of the
perspective that's been put
everything's been put into perspective
little one what has to get done what
matters
what doesn't and
obviously what matters most is is
getting healthy being back uh now with
the the twins who obviously have been
born to change everything um
for them for the family first
you you just want to you just want to
make sure they're
safe and healthy
uh
and and
and hope you don't screw it up because
there's
like
even a puppy a puppy like when you bring
it home at eight weeks
is so much more capable
than a baby right they can walk
they can get into stuff and eat
like um
they can go to the bathroom and it's not
just going to be all over a baby can do
nothing
and that's the thing too like it's it's
just
it's just funny you just realize the
difference to anyone who says there's no
difference between men and women i mean
within the first
day
or two days um
hillary's like oh yeah you know after
your feet
you know like like like you know
someone's like really good with a gun
like disassembling it like a marine or
something she's like oh yeah okay i turn
it over okay here you go burp him
farting okay change and
i absolutely see though now
how statistically
becoming a parent
makes people way more conservative you
know it puts in perspective we talk
about the changes going on
in the country in the world
and
if you had an audience
or p you could influence millions of
people for the better to change the
world that your kids would live in
would you ever run the risk of flipping
that switch off
and that puts it in perspective how
important
what we do is even though sometimes it
may seem silly um
just so that
you that everyone out there that us
you know here at the
show and hopefully my
hopefully my kids as they grow up
realize that
they're not alone you don't have to go
through it alone
um
as long as my lung cavity is not filled
up with bloody fluid
and that shouldn't be the case
come september
[Music]
you